>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Grant Harris: Good
afternoon and welcome
to the Library of Congress.
I am Grant Harris.
I am chief of the
European Division.
We are glad you are here for
this event entitled "Words,
Images, and Music: A Dialogue
on Torquato Tasso and the Arts"
at the Library of Congress.
We sponsor this event in
partnership with the Embassy
of Italy and the Italian
Cultural Institute here
in Washington.
Within the Library of Congress,
the European Division
is co-sponsoring
with the Music Division
and the Rare Book
and Special Collections
Division,
both of which have provided
really interesting treasures
that we were able to show
between 2:00 and 3:00 today.
We wish we could keep
them longer, but they have
to get back to their divisions.
Also co-sponsoring with us is
the Library's John W. Kluge
Center, which is just in
the rooms next door here.
They've graciously
let us use this room.
We would also like to thank
our wonderful speakers,
Dr. Laura Benedetti of
Georgetown University,
who is originally from
the Abruzzo Region
in Italy, in central Italy.
And Dr. Peter Lukehart of
the Center for Advanced Study
in the Visual Arts at the
National Gallery of Art,
a well-known art historian
both in D.C. and abroad.
Today's event celebrates
the birth
of the Italian Renaissance
author Torquato Tasso,
who was born on March 11 in
1544 in the town of Sorrento
on the Gulf of Naples.
He was the author
of the epic poem--
and I'm saying this in English
because I don't have the Italian
for this or was this in Latin
when it was first written?
In Italian, okay.
"Jerusalem Delivered,"
that's one
of the renderings in English.
That's not the only rendering,
but "Jerusalem Delivered."
Published in 1581, a work based
on the history of
the First Crusade.
The Library's collections
hold at least 760 items
in various formats
concerning Torquato Tasso,
and a good number are English
translations of his main works,
published in Britain and
in the United States.
We hope you have a pleasant
time at the library today,
and please come back
to use the collections.
The collections really are rich.
The Italian collections
are really incredible here.
Please turn off your cell
phones and recording devices
for the duration of the program.
Be aware that this
is being recorded
as a Library of Congress
webcast.
It's not live streaming, but
someday, many weeks from now,
it will be made available
on our webpages.
And I now give the floor to
our specialist for Italy,
Lucia Wolf, who has
organized this event today.
It's got lots of moving parts
with all the great items
that we were able
to show earlier.
Let me say also that
some people have asked
if those items will
be on display
in some way in the future.
And there will be at
least a list and Lucia,
I'll let you talk about
this, and you'll mention
that when you're up here, okay?
Well, thank you for being here.
I give you Lucia Wolf.
[ Applause ]
>> Lucia Wolf: So
I won't be long
because they are
the protagonists.
[laughter] And I'll
cut to the chase.
I had a longer, but
thank you for being here
for this wonderful occasion.
I thought hosting an event
to celebrate Torquato Tasso's
birth month would be as good
as any other occasion
to introduce one
of the greatest Italian
Renaissance writers
in our Italian program
repertoire
at the Library of Congress.
And I will mention what Grant
was referring to at the end,
but before going any further, I
want to thank all my colleagues
who have made this event
possible and have beared
with me during the
preparation of this event.
You all know who you are.
And most importantly, I
would like to thank the chief
of the European Division,
Grant Harris.
Finally, I want to
thank my husband.
Maybe he's here.
Okay. But -- [laughter]
That's okay.
He put up with a lot of
long extra hours of work,
so I decided to say
thank you to him.
I will not go over the
Library's collections too much,
because Grant has said most of
what we needed to know today
about the holdings
for Torquato Tasso.
But I would like to point
out that there are more
than 400,000 items in
our Italian collections,
and they are growing at the rate
of 6,000 new acquisitions
per year.
So it is a very, very
large collection.
If you are interested
in learning more
about the Italian collections,
please pick up a card,
my business cards.
Leave an e-mail if you
prefer and don't hesitate
to contact me, and I will give
you the best orientation I can.
[laughing] I'm still
exploring the collections.
I mean 400,000 items
are quite a few.
We will do many programs
to allow for that also.
These are occasions
for me, by the way,
to really discover
the collections
and share what the
bounty we have with you.
So let us move on
to our speakers,
because we had a
few logistical --
[laughing] problems
and technical that took
up some time, and we want to
give them all the time possible.
Dr. Laura Benedetti has taught
and currently teaches
Italian literature
at Georgetown University.
She holds a summa cum
laude from the University
of Rome La Sapienza, a masters
from the University of Alberta,
a Ph.D. from Johns
Hopkins University.
She taught for eight
years at Harvard,
where she become the John Loeb
-- I pronounce it like -- yep --
Associate Professor for the
Humanities before joining
Georgetown as the first Laura
and Gaetano De Sole Professor
of Contemporary Italian Culture.
Her publications include
"La sconfitta Di Diana,
un percorso per la Gerusalemme
liberata," "The Tigress
in the Snow: Motherhood
and Literature
in 20th Century Italy," the
edition and English translation
of Lucrezia Marinella's
"Esortazioni alle donne e agli
altri," and most recently,
her first novel,
"Un paese di carta,"
about which we had a
very vivacious talk here
at the Library last September.
And if you want to enjoy it, you
can go and watch the webcast.
It's posted online.
So let's move forward.
She has been a guest of
honor at annual meetings
of the American Association
of Italian Studies,
as well as the recipient
of the Flaiano International
Prize for Italian Studies.
She has also been awarded
the Wise Woman Award
for the National Organization
of Italian American Women,
and the gold medal
from Federazione
Associazioni Abruzzesi nele usa.
She is currently associate
editor and book review editor
of Italian culture
at the Journal
of the American Association
of Italian Studies.
And if you want to consult Dr.
Benedetti's books, we have most
of them -- I think all of
them -- here at the Library.
Our next guest, Dr. Peter
Lukehart, is Associate Dean
at the Center for Advanced
Study in the Visual Arts
at the National Gallery of
Art from 2001 to the present,
where he has a special
responsibility
for the fellowship program.
He received his Ph.D.
in Art History
from the Johns Hopkins
University.
From 1988 to 1990, he taught
at George Mason University,
another alma mater of mine.
[laughing] And then served
as a Mellon assistant curator
of the Southern Baroque
Painting at the National Gallery
of Art from 1990 to 1992.
From 1992 until 2001, he
held a joint appointment
at Dickenson College,
where he was director
of the college's museum,
the Trout Gallery,
and also assistant and
then associate professor
of art history.
In 2000, Lukehart organized the
exhibition and related website
"Writing on Hands:
Memory and Knowledge
in Early Modern Europe,"
which won the Dibner Award
in the History of Science.
He has a longstanding interest
the education and incorporation
of artists in the
early modern period.
His publications on this
subject include contributions
to the exhibition catalogue
"Taddeo and Federico Zuccaro:
Artist-Brothers in
Renaissance Rome"
and to The Artist's Workshop,
published under his editorship
in the Studies in the
History of Art series
at the National Gallery of Art.
He also served as editor
of the Accademia Seminars,
for which he wrote the
introduction and essay "Visions
and Divisions in
the Early History
of the Accademia di San Luca."
He is project director
for an online research
database entitled "The History
of the Accademia di San
Luca from 1590 to 1635:
Documents from Archivio
di Stato di Roma."
And please go and visit because
it is beautiful, it is amazing.
I went there and I have fond
memories of Accademia di--
>> Dr. Peter Lukehart: It
will soon grow to 1665.
[laughter]
>> Lucia Wolf: Wonderful.
[laughter] I loved going there.
In 2015, he contributed an
essay entitled "The Practice
and Pedagogy of Drawing in
the Accademia di San Luca"
to the volume -- I do
not really speak German,
but Lernt Zeichnen!
Techniken zwischen
Kunst und Wissenschaft.
>> Dr. Peter Lukehart:
Beautiful.
>> Lucia Wolf: Okay.
Did I do okay?
[laughter] The editors are Maria
Heilmann, Nino Nanobashvili,
Ulrich Pfisterer, and Tobias
Teutenberg for the exhibition
at the University of Heidelberg.
And I think I got to the end.
I wanted everybody to know what
wonderful speakers we have here
today, and this is
really a rare occasion
at the Library of Congress.
Please enjoy.
[ Applause ]
>> Dr. Laura Benedetti:
Thank you very much, Lucia,
for your kind introduction
and for all of your hard work
to make this event possible.
And thanks -- I also want
to extend my thanks
to all our sponsors.
I also want to of course
thank Peter Lukehart,
who was a brilliant
partner in this adventure.
And I also want to
remember Alberto Manai,
the former director of the
Italian Cultural Institute,
who first introduced
us to one another
and who was a very
strong supporter
of this kind of collaboration.
And of course, thank you
to all of you for deciding
to spend this Friday
afternoon with us.
Thank you.
I'm particularly pleased to
see some of my students here.
I know how hard it is
to leave our campus.
[laughter] So thank you, I
appreciate your being here.
And I recommend to all of you
to get close to the screens,
because the screens are not very
big and we are going to be --
I will be quoting passages.
Peter will be going through
the details of some images.
So please find a good spot.
This is a dialogue between
literature and the arts,
so Peter and I thought it
would be very appropriate
that our presentations
themselves were a dialogue.
So instead of having two
separate presentations,
we had one single
presentation and we'll go back
and forth discussing
features and episodes
of "Jerusalem Delivered."
We also thought that,
unfortunately,
Tasso doesn't quite enjoy
the same name recognition
as some other Italian writers
such as Dante or Machiavelli,
so we thought to make this event
accessible to anybody interested
in the subject matter,
regardless of their previous
exposure to the poet.
Anyway, chances are that
if you go to museums
or if you enjoy music, chances
are you have indeed been exposed
to Tasso.
A few years ago, a journalist
from the Washington Post,
Philip Kennicott wrote
a very beautiful article
on "Torquato Tasso, a Poet
Both Obscure and Ubiquitous."
And he said precisely, if
you had been to a museum
or to a concert of
Italian madrigals,
you know Tasso's
characters well,
even if you had never heard of
the poet whose former fame is
as astonishing as
his current oblivion.
[laughter] And to give you
an amusing example, I think,
of this phenomenon,
I chose a brochure
that the Baltimore Museum of
Art created to illustrate one
of its masterpieces from
the Rinaldo and Armida.
The Baltimore Museum of
Art put together a brochure
to foster appreciation
of art in children,
and so the children recognize
the various characters.
And there, at the bottom,
you can see it says
that the painting was
inspired by a poem
that was popular in the 1600s.
It tells the story from
the time of the Crusades.
Well, that poem is precisely
the "Gerusalemme liberata,"
or "Jerusalem Delivered,"
Tasso's masterpiece.
So there you have it, Tasso is
surreptitiously entering the
minds of innocent children
visiting the Baltimore Museum
of Art.
[laughter] Anyway,
it is kind of ironic
that Tasso would be
remembered mainly
for beautiful love episodes,
such as Rinaldo and Armida
because that is precisely
what they wanted to avoid.
[laughter] In fact, Tasso
wrote after the rediscovery
of Aristotle's poetics, when the
idea of the unity of the time
and space that Aristotle
had described
in Greek tragedy had
become essential,
even in the making
of [inaudible] poem.
And so Tasso wrote that
his poem not only had unity
of [inaudible] is the
story of the First Crusade,
but also unity of
agent, he said.
There is one main character,
the Christian [inaudible]
with Goffredo at its head
and Rinaldo as it's right.
So essentially this is what
"Jerusalem Delivered" is,
is a poem about the story of --
it's a fictional account
of the First Crusade.
So there's a very strong
tension towards the goal.
The first [inaudible] and
again, perhaps if you want
to come a little closer to
the screen, the first octet
of the second line mentions
the great tomb of the Savior,
so the final goal
of the mission,
and the epilogue --
[pause] -- sorry.
I'll be using Anthony Esolen's
beautiful translation throughout
the presentation.
And the epilogue also
mentions the very last line
of the great tomb.
So Jerusalem is the goal.
Jerusalem as both a
concrete place, a city,
but also the promise
of civil happiness
and a symbol of eternal bliss.
So not an easy thing to
capture when painters tried
to give the representation
of this idea.
>> Dr. Peter Lukehart:
Thank you.
Okay. Well, before
I begin my remarks,
I wanted to say a very warm
and deep thanks are necessary
for Lucia Wolf who helped
to organize this event,
and to my partner Laura.
This is, in a lot of
ways, a dream come true,
to be able to work
with a dear colleague
who knows so much about Tasso.
In the first glimpse
of Jerusalem
and Bernardo Castellos'
illustrations
for the 1590 Bartoli edition,
we see a bustling port
with anachronistic ships.
In the second canto, Castellos
represents Jerusalem as a kind
of medieval walled city, more
in keeping with the hill towns
of Italy than anything
in the Holy Land.
He is consistent, however,
in always depicting a centrally
planned church that must stand
for the church of
the Holy Sepulchre,
which is no longer
free-standing as it was
and as is often depicted here
in a 16th century
hand-colored engraving.
But rather, it's now enmeshed
in the walls of previous
and subsequent periods
of building.
What Castello has more
accurately communicated is
that Jerusalem is a walled city
and that the Holy sepulchre is
a polygonal temple surmounted
by a large dome.
And we'll see that
over and over again.
Similarly, the trees
and plantings
in the surrounding landscapes
are not palms, acacias,
cypresses, and cedars, but
the deciduous varieties found
in Europe.
This holds true for
Castello's contemporaries,
such as Sisto Badalocchio,
here in a scene from "Erminia."
We'll come back to this later,
but I wanted to emphasize here
that whereas Castello
indicates a pastoral scene
with the simplest of
elements, a rustic wooden fence
with a clear view
of Jerusalem behind.
Guercino provides
instead a vast landscape,
quite apart from the city, with
all manner of flora and fauna.
Again, of a type found more
in Italy than the Holy Land.
>> Dr. Laura Benedetti:
Beautiful.
Well, the road to Jerusalem
is long though, and if we read
that first stanza more closely,
we realize that there
is a problem.
There is the effort that
Goffredo, the leader,
has to make in order to bring
together his compagni errare,
or wandering companions
or straying men.
Errare is a very
powerful word in Italian
that conveys two
notions that I'll express
by two different
verbs in English.
Errare means both
to wander, to roam,
but also to be mistaken,
to be wrong, to err.
So in other words, a special
deviation from the path
that leads to Jerusalem
entails a more perversion.
But there is more.
Not only were Goffredo's
companions wandering off,
but also the narrator
presents himself as a
"peregrino errante," so
a wanderer gone astray.
And I would say not
only the characters
and the narrator are
always on the verge
of losing the right path, but
the poem itself, that it seems
on the verge of becoming
a different kind of poem,
a love poem, according to Tasso.
And this becomes
already very clear
in the first episode we're going
to discuss, the episode called
"Olindo and Sofronia."
The story is quite
complex, so I'm going
to try resume it in a few words.
Aladine, the terrible
ruler of Jerusalem,
suspects that the Christians
have stolen a sacred image
and threatens to kill them all.
Sofronia, a very modest
Christian woman, accuses herself
of the test in order to
spare the other Christians.
So she's sent to the stake, and
this is a very important detail
for our purposes, her veil
is taken away from her.
But at this point, Olindo,
who has been secretly loving
Sofronia, accuses himself
of the offense, at which
point Aladine gets really mad
and says, well, then I'm
going to kill both of them.
So they are taken to the stake
and they are tied back to back,
at which point, Olindo
starts this lament.
And I hope you can
read the translation.
I'll read the Italian.
[ Reading in Italian ]
There are already so
many characteristics
of Tasso's poetry
in this passage.
First, I'll say the
Baroque tendency
to turn the metaphorical
into the literal.
So the bonds that Olindo hoped
would tie him and Sofronia --
the metaphorical
bonds of love --
are turned into the
very harsh ropes
that are literally
tying them together.
The fire that Olindo hoped
would enflame both hearts turns
into the very real fire that
is about to kill both of them.
So there is that.
There is also Olindo's
frustrated eroticism,
which I think is very clear
in the last passage I read.
And there is Tasso's passion
for contrast and opposition.
In fact, Sofronia, when Sofronia
speaks, he uses a completely --
she -- she uses a
completely different tone,
and basically tells Olindo
to stop thinking about lips
and breasts and all of that.
[laughter] And to
repent and turn his heart
over to eternal life that
they are about to achieve.
And I would say also
that this is an example,
this episode is an example of
Tasso's musical sensibility.
Because you really can imagine
this on a stage or as an opera.
Because first, you have Olindo,
the lad broke his sorrows
in this cry, so a
very high voice.
And Sofronia, who
replies tenderly
with words of good advice.
And then you have the
choir that joins in,
but even the choir is
divided into groups.
You have the Muslims, here the
crowd of pagans raised a cry,
so they are very moved by
the fate of the two lovers,
or the two martyrs almost.
And the Christians
were a little afraid
by the difficult
situation, so they quietly
and low, the Christians wept.
So even there, you have
two different tombs.
And finally, you even have
the effect of the audience.
A something, who can
say what, unusual, soft,
into the hard heart
of their ruler crept.
"Un non so che d'inusitato,"
who can say what.
Je ne sais pas quoi, which
is really Torquato Tasso's
trademark, and is a really
very prominent in this passage.
I should say, I should add that
the episode has a happy ending
because Clorinda, the Muslim
warrior woman, arrives
and she senses, she
understands that Olindo
and Sofronia are innocent.
She convinces Aladine
to release them.
And so the two can get married,
which is excellent for Olindo,
not so great for Sofronia.
[laughter] In fact, the last
line says she will not scorn
to spend her life with
Olindo, which is not exactly,
you know, a warm [inaudible].
[laughter]
>> Dr. Peter Lukehart:
Well, we'll see the way
that the artists interpret this.
[laughter] I think
they warm her up.
[ Laughter ]
>> Dr. Laura Benedetti:
Oh, yeah, you're right.
>> Dr. Peter Lukehart: Okay.
So this scene provides, in a
nutshell, the principle themes
of "Jerusalem Iiberata," but
the Christian maiden, Sofronia,
and the Christian soldier,
Olinda, who loves her,
have sacrificed themselves.
Sofronia, in order to protect
her people from Aladino's wrath,
and Olindo in order to
protect his paramour.
The leader of the Muslim
forces, Aladino, instead orders,
as we've just heard, both of
them to be burned at the stake.
And just at the moment
when the fires are lit
and all seems lost, Clorinda,
the fearless Muslim warrior --
and I'm going to be using the
word Muslim because I don't want
to have quite the
sense of antagonism
that is inherent
in Tasso himself.
I don't want to start
range wars over that.
[laughter] In any case,
so that's my vocabulary.
And she will intervene
and spares them.
In the earliest illustrated
edition by Bernardo Castello,
and here -- is Diane
DeGrazia still here?
I'm going to just make
a shout-out to her.
She was one of my earliest
mentors and knows so much
about these prints, and I still
go back to her work all the time
for information about the
prints of the Carracci.
In any case, in this first
edition that had engravings both
by Giacomo Franco and
Agostino Carracci.
In this image preceding the
second canto, Castello focuses
on Goffredo and his troops
and their encampment.
By contrast, the scene of the
near martyrdoms of Sofronia
and Olindo is relegated to
a small corner of the plaza.
Do we see that?
Let me see.
It's not coming out.
It's in the walled area.
There's a very faint --
I'm sorry, kind of
an oval around it.
Can you see that in
the upper right corner?
That's how tiny it is, what's
going on in the background.
Okay? [laughter] One could
easily overlook this section,
and I did myself the
first time I looked at it,
which is shown here
as a lesser episode
within the greater narrative.
If you look carefully, however,
you see that Castello does
in fact illustrate the
very moment when Olindo
and Sofronia are at the stake.
The fire's lit and Clorinda
appears in the nick of time.
In the third canto, however,
Castello chose instead
to highlight the first
violent encounter
between Clorinda and Tancred.
And you see her here with
her shield over her head.
She's a little bit to
the left of center.
So their first meeting
in battle is here.
As Laura has explained,
Tasso describes the loss
of Sofronia's veil and
thus, of her defenses
against the false charge
of the theft of the icon.
Most artists, from Castello
to Cochin which was also
in the little exhibition
out here, shows Sofronia
as modestly dressed,
but lacking a veil.
Thus, I was surprised to
find the Neapolitan painter,
Mattia Preti, depicted
both Sofronia
And Olindo completely nude here
in the version at the Getty,
and utterly humiliated
and defenseless
until Clorinda arrives
majestically on her steed
to interrupt the
lighting of the pyre.
A moment that could
have ended in martyrdom
and sacrifice turns
instead to one of salvation.
And rather than being consumed
by the flames, as proto-martyrs
to the cede of Jerusalem,
Olindo and Sofronia will be free
to enjoy the flames of passion.
So I think maybe Olindo got
his wish here at this time.
[laughter] The sensual
and emotional intensity
of Preti's painting falls away
in the print from Didot edition,
illustrated by Cochin.
And I'm putting them side by
side, where the forlorn Olindo
and Sofronia are fully dressed
in what could be confused
with 18th century
pastoral shepherd costumes.
[laughter]
>> Dr. Laura Benedetti: This is
all very beautiful, of course,
but one may wonder
whether an episode
like this really should have
a place in the Christian act
that Tasso is trying to build.
And when Tasso started
circulating the manuscript,
the readers were puzzled.
They thought that the episode
was introduced too early
in the poem.
It's only the second canto.
They thought it did not
have any link whatsoever
with the main action.
They thought it was too lyrical
and too sensual,
as we have seen.
And they thought that the end
and the happy conjugal
ending was contrived.
And so Tasso himself, in his
letters, he goes back and forth
between defending his creation
and acknowledging its
flaws and its limits.
In the meantime, he
becomes a little restless.
Perhaps his mental health
starts to disappear a bit.
And for reasons that are
not completely clear,
he is imprisoned in an asylum.
And here, you can see the
rendering of Eugene Delacroix,
"Tasso in the Asylum" from 1839.
Tasso was imprisoned in 1579,
and he will not regain his
freedom until seven years later.
And when it becomes clear that
Tasso would stay in the asylum
for a while, the people who
had this manuscript decided
to publish it against his will.
And Tasso never endorsed
any of the editions
of "Jerusalem Delivered"
that came out.
In fact, for the rest of his
life, he continued to work
on the poem, trying to
get his poem the shape
that he really thought was
fitted for a Christian epic.
And in 1593, so two years before
his death, he finally published
"Jerusalem Conquered,"
"Gerusalemme conquistata."
I'm making the English title
up because it's never been
translated into English.
This, Tasso wrote, is the poem
for which I want
to be remembered.
This is the heavenly Jerusalem,
while "Jerusalem Delivered"
is the earthly Jerusalem.
And Tasso died in 1595, so only
two years after the publication
of "Gerusalemme conquistata."
And perhaps he was spared the
last insult, the realization
that the poem for
which he wanted
to be remembered will
never manage to replace
"Jerusalem Delivered"
in the hearts
and the minds of this public.
So the editorial history
of "Jerusalem Delivered"
is quite complex.
>> Dr. Peter Lukehart:
Thank you.
Having fought with censors for
years, as we've just learned,
upon the reluctant publication
of "Gerusalemme" in 1581,
Tasso had a best
seller on his hands.
Not only was his epic poem
immediately famous and printed
in multiple editions,
it had been published
during his lifetime
with various commentaries,
and soon thereafter,
with illustrations.
It was analogous to
getting a movie deal
for an early modern author.
The illustrated editions
both acknowledged
and expanded the
author's renown.
At the same time, Tasso's
"Gerusalemme" become the subject
of withering criticism from his
contemporaries, most damningly
from the members of the Academia
della Crusca in Florence.
I am illustrating
here one of the books
from the pro-Tasso camp
by Lorenzo Giacomini,
a member of the Academia
degli Alterati.
But even Galileo weighed
in on this matter of the
"Gerusalemme," but
he was against Tasso.
And yet this critical
discussion, however unsettling
to the poet, also served
to trumpet his fame.
We also witness the
significance of Tasso's success
in the jealousy of other poets,
who hoped, usually vainly,
to embark on a similar
course toward fame.
Tasso's contemporary, Gabriello
Chiabrera, for example,
wrote to the artist Bernardo
Castello, who sent him a copy
of the 1590 edition
of the "Gerusalemme"
that he had illustrated,
as we've now been looking
at many times, and expressed
these co-mingled ideas.
"For the gift of
the "Gerusalemme,"
I offer infinite thanks,
for I see in the book excellent
figures of poetry and painting.
I, who have great affection
for Tasso, hold this book
in my hands at every
hour, thus at every hour,
I will be in the presence of
your affection and your genius.
But about your compliments
for my Amedeide,
I thank you for the sweet
inducement to write poetry.
Nonetheless, I could not
hope to accomplish it,
nor even could I hope to achieve
such honor, or more precisely,
I could not accept it,
being that I am, by nature,
an enemy of presumption."
Evidently, however, Chiabrera
got over his aversion
to presumption, for
about a decade later,
he wrote to Castello to ask for
a frontispiece for the Amedeide.
And to discuss, or can
be surprised at all,
the details for illustrations
of his epic poem
that was published in 1620.
These anecdotes point
to the fact that Tasso's
"Gerusalemme" was a text
believed by literatti
and artists from the
moment of its publication,
second to an important
cultural reality of the period.
Poets and painters had occasion
to correspond and relatedly
that poets and painters took
inspiration from one another.
Further, the special
relationships that existed
between artists, including
musicians, as we'll see,
an poets, often result in
some of the most interesting
and influential collaborations
in our shared culture.
Such was the case for Castello,
who was introduced to Tasso
in 1576, after "Gerusalemme"
had been completed as a text,
but before it was
ever published.
In May 1586, Tasso wrote a
letter that Castello had --
in his letter, that Castello
had passed through Ferrara
on his way back from
Venice and left with him --
that is, with Tasso --
a series of drawings.
We see some of Castello's
drawings here.
I'm not sure they were ever
the same ones that were
in Tasso's hands, but
they're from the right period.
Relating to my poem, as he said.
Though it is doubtful,
as I said,
these are the exact drawings,
they show that there's
a cordial friendship
between the artist and the poet.
More importantly, these
exchanges cemented the decision
to have Castello's drawings
included in a new luxury edition
of the "Gerusalemme,"
published by Bartoli in 1590.
We do not have detailed
critical responses from Tasso,
but in a letter from
their mutual friend,
Donangelo Grillo --
Angelo, that is, sorry.
The poet spoke frankly about
the process of co-creation.
And I'm quoting here.
"With regards to my book, I
have not changed my opinion.
It would not be necessary to
change many of the figures
by Castello, who is faster
at creating the drawings
than I am at dealing with them.
Nonetheless, his drawing
must be similar to the idea
that I have envisioned for it."
So he really wanted there to
be some kind of consonances.
I think this is an interesting
kind of irony in the fact
that he's simultaneously not
wanting it to be published,
but wanting to have his
hands in whatever comes out,
maybe a new story
to be told later.
>> Dr. Laura Benedetti:
Yes, yes.
>> Dr. Peter Lukehart:
Although there is a slight sense
of reprimand in Tasso's
statement
because Castello is getting
ahead of him, by and large,
he liked the figures and
the artist's conception
of the scenes to be illustrated.
The existence of these
fragmentary notes suggest
that Tasso and Castello
conducted a frequent
and candid correspondence,
now lost.
The above letter bespeaks
an intimate collaboration
between the poet and the
artist that began in earnest
around 1586 and continued
at least
through the publication in 1590.
Furthermore, it points
to the centrality
of the Genoise literary
and artistic culture
in the publication of the
early editions of Tasso.
For it was in Genoa, too,
that the physician illiterato,
named Giulio Guastavini,
wrote his anotatsioni,
that is his commentaries on
the "Gerusalemme," which helped
to redirect the argument
about Tasso's place
in the literary pantheon
from that of a rival
to his contemporary ariosto, to
that of a rival of the ancients,
that of Homer and Virgil.
Together, Castello, Guastavini,
and the publisher, Bartoli,
increased Tasso's fame
throughout Europe.
On a recent trip to Genoa,
I had the opportunity
to examine two examples of the
first edition, one of which
from canto quinto,
has a little dingbat,
and that's why the
arrow is there.
At the end you'll see
in pen next to it.
And so canto quinto and
canto quinto are reversed.
So this must be from one
of the very earliest,
earliest editions, before
it was in its final form.
And as we see here,
the images are flipped.
The sharp details
and the rich ink
of the advanced copy gives some
sense of the original appearance
of these illustrations.
And it's just in
pristine condition.
I recommend your going there.
Washington too, as you've seen
in the exhibition, is fortunate
to have an outstanding
exemplar of the first edition
in the Library of Congress'
Rosenwald collection.
In addition to the outstanding
quality of the text and images,
to which we will make frequent
reference in the course
of our dialogue, the Rosenwald
edition is ruled throughout.
I wanted you to see this.
It's very interesting
and I'd be happy
to hear what people
think about it.
Close looking at the lines of
the ruling and those of the text
and prints suggest to me that
they were intended as guides
for the printing process.
And if this is true, this would
make the Rosenwald volume also
one of the earliest in
the succession of copies
that proceeded the release
of "Gerusalemme" to
a reading public.
>> Dr. Laura Benedetti:
In order to move
from the earthly
Jerusalem to the celestial,
heavenly Jerusalem,
Tasso was merciless
in eliminating the episodes
that had been very successful,
but they did not correspond
to his idea of the form.
And so Olinda and Sofronia
is one of those episodes,
so in this [inaudible] just
eliminated it from his poem.
[laughter] Which is too bad,
because also Sofronia is one
of the very few Christian
women in "Jerusalem Delivered."
This is a striking
feature of the poem.
The two different sides
are differentiated,
not only in terms of
religion, but also of gender.
Apart from Sofronia in
"Jerusalem Delivered,"
there is only another minor
female character, Guilepe,
was also led to the theme
of marriage, and that's it.
Apart from that, it's
exclusively a male only.
On the contrary, women are some
of the most important characters
on the Muslim side or the
pagan side, as Tasso said,
which creates a very
strong attraction
between the two groups, and
many vital areas, many episodes
in which the rules of
love, the laws of love,
prevail over the laws of war.
And so it's very
interesting, you know,
how these two groups
are differentiated also
in visual terms.
>> Dr. Peter Lukehart:
Absolutely, right.
Which is what I will
be talking about next.
Beginning again in these images
with the Bartoli edition,
Castello made several easily
identifiable differences
between the Muslim and
Christian soldiers.
In the vast Cecil B.
DeMille panoramas that we see
of the battlefield, Castello
clearly marks the Muslim
soldiers as wearing turbans,
carrying rectangular shields,
usually with a crescent moon,
and occasionally bearing
a large moustache.
The Christians are shown
with heavy metal helmets
and metal armor in the form of
cuirass, with shoulder guards
or at least a breast plate
protecting their thighs
in an ancient style
leather skirt.
Their legs and knees
are otherwise bear,
and on their feet, they
wear Roman style breeves.
In doing a bit of
research on armor,
I learned that during
the First Crusade,
soldiers would more
typically have worn chainmail.
Plate armor was only
introduced in the 13th century.
So for both the poorly
protected Muslim troops
and the Christian
three-quarter covered soldiers,
anachronisms abound.
Also imprecisions.
However, Castello succeeds
in allowing the viewer
to scan the armies and figure
out which side they
represent very quickly.
The women are sometimes
shown in full armor.
Here we see Clarinda and
Armida in different sides.
But at other times, they wear
long, flowing skirts and gowns,
as we'll see soon enough with
our discussion of Armida.
These anomalies could be seen
as either breaches of decorum
or verisimilitude and
the Aristotelian unities,
or as necessary visual evidence
that discloses identity in order
to preserve the greater
integrity of the narrative.
There's another film version
by Carlo Ludovico Bragaglia,
I wanted to share with you, in
this wonderful poster from 1957.
This clearly, we know
exactly what we're looking at.
And I recommend it to you
as well worth a binge watch.
[laughter] In addition
to the poster,
there's some other
film stills online,
and here we see Cinecitta's
version of a swords
and sandals extravaganza.
The stereotypes of the Muslim
soldier need no comment.
Of course, these notions of
difference, whether gender based
or cultural, also implicated
both readers and viewers
in the early modern period.
The masking of the
Islamic soldiers as a vast,
undifferentiated army, for
instance, lessens one's empathy
for the individual who
might be captured, banished,
or worse, slaughtered.
And many times, people are said
to be torn to pieces or cut
to pieces in the narrative.
Equally interesting, as Laura
has pointed out, is that women
in the "Gerusalemme" tend to
be the characters who best
and most effectively disguise
themselves in order to cross
over between religions,
cultures, and amorous pursuits.
>> Dr. Laura Benedetti: Yes.
As an example of the love
that unites members of the --
or at least tries
to unite members
of the two opposite groups,
we may look no further
than the episode of
Erminia among the shepherds.
Erminia is a Muslim queen who
had been captured by Tancredi,
a Christian knight,
and later released.
But only literally
released, as Tasso says,
because metaphorically, she's
still a prisoner of Tancredi,
because she has fallen
in love with him.
And so although she's now
safe within Jerusalem,
she longs to be with
Tancredi, so she ventures out.
But in order to venture out, she
needs to steal Clorinda's armor,
so we see this other theme
of mistaken identities,
identity confusion.
And so she ventures out,
but two guards see her.
They think she's Clorinda,
and they start chasing her.
So she runs away,
she gallops away,
and then when she's finally
exhausted, she dismounts
from the horse and
she falls asleep.
And when she wakes up, she
wakes up in a different poem.
[laughter] And as
this passage again --
I hope you can read
the translation.
[ Reading in Italian ]
So notice that, first of all,
now Erminia reveals
her true identity.
She's not a warrior,
she's a woman.
But notice also that the
landscape around Jerusalem,
that had been described by
Tasso, is a desert, essentially,
now becomes the setting
for a [inaudible].
It is literally a different
poem with the shepherds
who play and sing tunes.
>> Dr. Peter Lukehart: That's
a great segue, thank you.
[laughter] And as mentioned
earlier, and just now,
pastoral landscapes became one
of the most believed settings
for 17th century
artists and litterati.
Thus, the episode of Erminia
and the shepherds is a
frequent subject from Tasso
in prints and paintings.
In addition to the leafy
and abundant landscapes,
artists were drawn to
Tasso's description
of two compelling themes,
the sound of the
children playing pipes
that attracted Erminia
in the first place
to the shepherds' home and the
quick succession of emotions
that the young boys and
their father experience
when they first see her.
You'll see, it's very
minimally understandable,
but if you know the poem,
you understand there's a
little [inaudible] moment here
where they're scared,
they don't know.
They think she is a warrior.
Okay? And at this point,
her identity is completely
hidden beneath Clorinda's armor
and they are sore afraid.
The minute that Erminia
removes her helmet, however,
the shepherds are put at ease,
and then entreat her to remain
with them, and she's tempted.
This scene finds
many interpreters,
including Geurchino -- [pause]
Sisto Badalocchio, and others.
I wanted to make certain that
you would at least be introduced
to this clever reimagining
of this scene
by the Florentine artist Santi
di Tito, as a family portrait.
Here, the mother is Erminia,
the father is the shepherd,
and the three children
are the pipers.
Further, I wanted to bring to
your attention something closer
at hand, at the National
Gallery of Art.
We are fortunate to have two
grand 18th century canvases
from a Venetian palace
painted by the brothers Antonio
and Gian Francesco Guardi,
one depicting Erminia
and the shepherds
and the other Carlo
and Ubaldo encounter the sirens
while searching for Rinaldo,
a scene that we'll
come up to next.
>> Dr. Laura Benedetti:
Erminia has [inaudible].
Erminia was one of Tasso's
most original creations,
starting with the name.
Tasso invented the name Erminia.
And yet, as you can
imagine, when Tasso went back
to his poem, he thought
that there was no place
for this [inaudible]
interlude the Christian epoch,
so also Erminia disappears.
However, some other episodes
were too tightly embedded
in the poem.
They were, in fact,
not episodes,
but full-fledged stories, and
could not easily be eliminated.
And one of the most famous is
the story of Rinaldo and Armida.
Armida is a Muslim
enchantress who manages
to distract many Christians
from their mission.
She's in fact, I would claim,
Goffredo's real antagonist,
because Goffredo represents
a centripetal force
that binds the army together and
propels it towards Jerusalem,
while Armida embodies
the opposite principle,
multiplicity, variety,
a centripetal force
that encourages the soldiers
who follow their instinct
instead of their duty.
And Armida is very close
to celebrating her triumph
when Rinaldo -- so the imaginary
ancestor of the [inaudible]
through which Tasso writes,
as well as the right arm
of the Christian
army in Tasso's view
of the single agent in his poem.
Rinaldo is asleep and is
about to be killed by Armida.
And then Armida makes
the fatal mistake.
She looks at Rinaldo.
Rinaldo's so beautiful, and
she falls in love with him.
And the last two lines say
"e'n su la vaga fronte pende
omai si che par Narciso al
fonte," like Narcissus
at the pool,
she hung upon his lovely face.
So already from the
very beginning,
this is a very strong
narcissistic element in the love
between Armida and Rinaldo.
>> Dr. Peter Lukehart:
Thank you.
Laura has set the
stage beautifully
for Nicolas Poussin's
"Rinaldo and Armida."
In his book on Poussin,
"The Poetics of Painting,"
Jonathan Unglaub offers
a penetrating analysis
of the artist's interpretation.
He calls our attention
to the sparseness
of the barren landscape and the
single fervor of Eros or Cupid,
rather than having
an army of puttee
that many other artists
would do.
The better to focus our
attention on the moment
when love, literally love,
love as amour, love as Cupid,
restrains Armida from plunging
her dagger into Rinaldo's chest.
Only love, he says, has the
power to disarm hostility.
Just so, Armida's hatred
transforms into intense love,
which is communicated
both in the interruption
of her murderous plot, and
in the intensity of her gaze,
squarely locked,
on Rinaldo's face.
In the next scene,
also by Poussin,
the smitten Armida prepares to
take the sleeping Rinaldo back
to her enchanted island
and one of the few versions
to show the actual transport.
I'm leading us through
the narrative here.
This is by Domenico Fiasella,
one of my favorites from Genoa,
who depicts Armida's flying
chariot laden with flowers.
>> Dr. Laura Benedetti:
Oh, this is beautiful.
And so, in fact, Armida
decides to take Rinaldo
to the isola fortunata,
which are usually identified
with Canary Islands.
And so she takes him there
in her beautiful garden,
which is also a beautiful
building with beautiful paths.
[ Reading in Italian ]
So the first word here
is "tondo," circular.
So Armida's circular
universe is the negation
of Goffredo's straight
itinerary towards Jerusalem.
So Armida and Rinaldo enjoy
the garden's eternal spring.
>> Dr. Peter Lukehart: Right.
Well, I think we'll
move to the --
>> Dr. Laura Benedetti:
Yeah, to the next one.
The garden's attempt --
>> Dr. Peter Lukehart: We'll
see the gardens in a minute.
[laughter]
>> Dr. Laura Benedetti:
Do not worry.
Do not despair.
[laughter] But we also see
what Rinaldo and Armida do
in the garden, and
among other things,
they perform complex
love rituals.
In particular, the scene of the
mirror, where Armida takes care
of her hair and she looks
at herself in the mirror,
and Rinaldo helps her.
[ Reading in Italian ]
I must have read these
verses a hundred times
and I still have problems
understanding precisely what
they mean, right?
They are so beautiful, so
musical, and yet, when you try
to find exactly what this is
saying, you are in trouble.
And the thing, this is not --
it's not that Tasso's making a
mistake, but on the contrary.
Here, it's both representing
Armida's charm and pointing
at the fact that that
charm leads to confusion,
to gender confusion,
and also literally
to the loss of mean [?].
I think this is why this
line is so problematic.
>> Dr. Peter Lukehart: Exactly.
And we see one of the
scenes here, again,
from the Bartoli edition here
at the Library of Congress.
As diverting and
interesting as these parts
of the love story are, some
of the most fascinating
from an art historical
perspective are those
that involve gazes
and reflections.
While under Armida's
spell, Rinaldo is incapable
of seeing himself as he is.
Rather, he only perceives
himself
through his reflection
in her eyes.
And we'll see that
better in other versions.
Fight, Annibale Carracci,
who understood exactly
what Tasso was trying
to say, I think.
[laughter] So if we had more
time, I would develop an idea
of pictorial intelligence,
which I would say is equally
as refined as literally
intelligence.
But I think he really gets it.
Here, Armida's pictured as
gazing at her reflection
in the mirror, while
Rinaldo stares rather vapidly
into her eyes.
He's no longer dressed
as a soldier.
The only thing that's
left is he sword.
I think we'll hear
more about that.
His limply placed sword,
without saying more.
[laughter] And he is now a
luce cordier in her enthrall.
>> Dr. Laura Benedetti: Yes.
Absolutely.
And this is a love that can
only blossom in a place removed
from war, from battle,
from the making of history.
But history and war enter the
garden when Carlo and Ubaldo,
two Christian warriors,
manage to fulfill their
mission, and rescue Rinaldo.
They take advantage of
Armida's momentary absence
and present Rinaldo
with a shield.
And this shield, interestingly
enough, is another mirror.
But as Maggie Gunsberg
has pointed out,
is a mirror that serves
the opposite function
than Armida's mirror.
So while Armida's mirror
[inaudible] narcissism
and confusion, this mirror
instills guilt and awareness.
In other words, by looking at
his reflection in the mirror,
Rinaldo sees himself
as an unwanted member
of a social group, of
the Christian Army.
Basically, he has
recovered this new sense
of social expectations,
if we can say so.
And indeed, the dangling
sword that fell
at his side is very prominent
also in Tasso's lines here.
>> Dr. Peter Lukehart:
Thank you.
It is not until Carlo and
Ubaldo, who have been sent
by Goffredo and the Christian
troops to retrieve Rinaldo,
espy their commander that they
helped to reveal their leader
to himself through
seeing his own reflection.
And here, from a Florentine
anonymous fresco cycle.
But do you see?
It's one of the rare,
rare versions
where they show the actual
moment of the reflective shield,
which is supposed to have
like a diamond-like surface.
Am I right about that?
>> Dr. Laura Benedetti:
Yeah, absolutely.
>> Dr. Peter Lukehart:
And this weapon,
a much more masculine one,
the polished diamond
surface of the shield.
And in that moment, Rinaldo
awakens to his true appearance
and at once vows to
leave Armida's island.
To return briefly to the
version by Annibale Carraci.
Do you see in the background
Carlo and Ubaldo with the shield
that glints just a
little bit of light,
hinting at what's to come.
It's again, just --
>> Dr. Laura Benedetti: Yeah.
It's fascinating
how painters tend
to represent various
moments in the story, right?
>> Dr. Peter Lukehart: Exactly.
>> Dr. Laura Benedetti:
With the different paints
and [inaudible].
Well, as you've probably
figured out by now,
none of the love stories of the
"liberata" had a happy ending.
[laughter] This is what
Tasso himself wrote
in one of his letters.
But no story is as tragic as the
one of Tancredi and Clorinda.
We have already mentioned
these two characteristics.
Clorinda is the warrior woman
who encountered to rescue Olindo
and Sofronia, while Tancredi
is the Christian soldier
who Erminia loved.
But Tancredi did
not love Erminia
because he loved Clorinda.
He loved Clorinda simply because
he had seen her once by a stream
without her helmet on.
[laughter] And yet, fallen
madly in love with her.
And it's a love that
becomes an obsession.
They have very few --
in fact, you mentioned,
one of the few encounters
in battle they had
before canto twelve,
which is really their canto, the
canto of Tancredi and Clorinda.
Canto twelve begins with an ero
note, like Virgil, notes errata.
So it was night time,
it was night time,
which seems a Meredith
chronological remark,
but actually introduces one
of the main protagonists
of the canto, the knight which
generates confusion, darkness,
and tragedy for
misunderstandings.
Clorinda is within
Jerusalem and she's restless.
She thinks that she should go
outside the wall of Jerusalem
to set on fire a war
machine, a mobile tower,
that the Christians have used
quite successfully to date.
But in order to go out
unnoticed, she decides not
to wear her usual armor,
and she dons a dark armor.
[ Reading in Italian ]
"An omen full of
fear," [inaudible].
So there seems to be something
strange about Armida --
sorry, about Clorinda's armor.
And her servant, Arsete,
who has taken care of her
since she was a baby, decides
that this is the right time
to tell Clorinda her real story.
The real story's quite
complex, but the main points are
that Clorinda was born in
Ethiopia, and she was born
from Christian parents.
And then, through a complex set
of circumstances, her mother had
to entrust her to Arsete.
Arsete had raised her as Muslim.
And he had neglected
to baptize her
as Clorinda's mom
had recommended.
But now, Arsete just had
a dream and in the dream,
St. George has appeared
and has urged him
to baptize Clorinda
before it is too late.
And this is the story that
Arsete tells Clorinda,
but Clorinda decides,
nevertheless, that she wants
to -- that she believes in her
fate and decides to venture
out to complete this mission.
And in fact, she goes out,
she sets the tower on fire.
Then she tries to get
back into Jerusalem,
but the door is locked
at the wrong time.
And this is what Tasso
expresses beautifully, I think,
with this octet, which begins,
"Aperta e l'Aurea porta,"
so the golden gate is open.
And then it ends
with the door is --
"e chiusa a poi la porta..."
[reading in Italian]
The door is swung to.
Clorinda is shut out.
And the following octet starts
by emphasizing the same concept.
[in Italian] Shut alone is she.
So she's really in this no
man's or no woman's land,
where she's among enemies,
although those enemies,
she has just learned,
are really the group
to which she belongs by birth.
Yet, it's night time, so
Clorinda hopes that thanks
to her disguise, she'll
be able to go unnoticed.
And in fact, she almost manages,
but Tancredi manages to see her.
And Tancredi makes
a tragic mistake.
"Solo Tancredi avien che
lei conosca," of this,
it chanced that the one man
[inaudible] was Tancred.
"Conosca," Tasso says, which
is a very ambiguous verb.
In modern Italian, the
difference between conoce,
so to meet for the first time,
and the Greek "gignosko,"
to recognize, is very clear.
But this was not the
case in the 16th century,
where conoce could mean
either thing, you know,
convey either meaning.
So for a moment,
the reader thinks
that Tancredi recognized
Clorinda,
but what follows makes clear
that that's not at all the case.
In fact, Tancredi thinks
that Clorinda is a man,
and he follows her and
challenges her to a dual.
And this "Va girando
colei l'alpestre cima,"
she sought some other gate to
enter town, is the beginning
of Monteverdi's cCombattimento
that you'll discuss later on.
So they begin this furious fight
that has some really tragic
and almost disturbing
undertones, where the language
of love and the language
of war coincide.
For instance, this passage.
[ Reading in Italian ]
So for a tragic perversion,
what should have been a
lover's embrace is transferred
into a man and his deadly grip.
So they fight throughout the
night, but as the sun rises
from the east, Tancredi
formulates a request.
He says, you know,
it's really a shame
that we don't know
each other's name.
Who are you?
And this is a very
common request
in [inaudible] literature,
but the reader can
perceive a tragic urgency
and a tragic irony in request.
His problem is precisely
that he doesn't know the name
of his mysterious opponent.
But Clorinda refuses
to reveal her identity,
and the fight resumes.
And Clorinda is wounded to
death and she's about to die.
And as she -- sorry.
As she is about to die,
she formulates a request.
She asks that she be baptized.
So she asks to be baptized.
At which point, Tancredi
goes to a nearby stream,
fills his helmet with water, and
goes back to the dying warrior.
And as you can see here,
he has almost a premonition
while he's trying
to free the warrior's
face from the helmet.
[reading in Italian] And then
there is the tragic revelation.
[ Reading in Italian ]
And notice how these last
lines with their staccato --
with their rapid
succession of short,
essential sentences
conveys the change
in perspective in Tancredi.
Because after that point,
Tancredi has been fighting,
running, and chasing ghosts,
but only now he realizes
what he has really done.
So Tancredi and Clorinda,
probably the most
tragic creation in the
"Jerusalem Delivered."
An episode that is at the same
time coherent as a narration
and skillful as a
work of poetry.
Tasso uses a number of
poetic devices, alteration,
[inaudible], assonance,
and broad dichotomies,
male and female, death and
salvation, night and day
to tell a suspenseful story.
But the thing that the --
the real reason for the enduring
success of these episodes lies
in its universal scene.
Tancredi's problem
is that he fails
to recognize his beloved
until it is too late.
This is the trend that units the
different stages of the episode
from that first ironic
[in Italian], of this,
it chanced that the one
man aware was Tancred,
to the tragic revelation,
[in Italian].
Notice that the verbs are the
same, conocere [inaudible].
Perhaps in the translation,
that is lost a bit.
But those are the same
verbs that Tasso uses.
So therefore, the real theme
of the episode is the failure
to acknowledge, recognize,
understand, embrace [inaudible],
a theme that resonates
throughout the century
and for all of us.
And to think, this is
the reason why Tancredi
and Clorinda would continue to
strike each other as warriors
and miss each other
as lovers in the works
of many painters and
composers, right?
Because it's an extremely
successful episode.
>> Dr. Peter Lukehart:
Absolutely.
As we'll see, and interpreted
in many different ways,
or different aspects
are highlighted.
Throughout this dialogue,
I've been concentrating
on the early graphic
representations of Gerusalemme
because they were most often
the first ones produced,
and in many ways,
the most influential
to the artists who followed.
Not only did a significant
number
of artists own the
illustrated editions of Tasso,
which provided rich
visual material,
they were undoubtedly
respond to the argumente
and the privileging of
the particular scenes
by the commentators
and the illustrators.
Among the first of
the painted responses
to Tasso is a powerfully
foreshortened view
of the conversion of Clorinda
by Domenico Tintoretto.
Having fought through the
entire night, Tancredi
and Clorinda are seen just as
dawn breaks in the background.
Tintoretto augmented
the terrestrial light
with a dazzling, heavenly vision
of two seraphim accompanying
the dove of the Holy Ghost.
Any of you who know
scenes of Baptism
of Christ often see the
same kinds of images.
This divine apparition serves
as a kind of exclamation point
to the counter-reformation
themes that adhere
to Tasso's epic, though they
are not specifically described
by him.
Together, the angles in
breaking dawn, turn the carpet
of plants a golden hue.
The raking angles of the
figures draw our attention
to the subtle details
of Tasso's verses.
Clorinda's ashen face, and
these are Tasso's words,
"like violets mixed with
lilies, and her mortal wound,
from whence blood has stained
her blouse," on one hand,
and the swiftly running
Tancred -- note for instance,
his extended left leg --
who arrives with the
water for baptism
at the precise moment
she's about to expire.
By contrast, Sisto Badalocchio
orients the scene parallel
to the picture plane
and draws the viewer
in with a brilliant light
that bathes Clorinda's
bare and bloodied chest.
Although we can again see
dawn breaking in the distance,
Clorinda, having declared her
conversion and receiving baptism
from the hand of
Tancred, herself appears
to be a source emanating light.
There is no heavenly apparition.
Rather, a more naturalistic
or in the words of the period,
"verisimile," kind
of interpretation.
Yet this internally generated
light beatifies Clorinda,
who looks more like a martyred
saint than a dying war heroine.
Similarly, Badalocchio
sets his narrative
in a verdant landscape far
from the walls of Jerusalem,
which we barely glimpse
in the background.
In the same -- excuse me.
At the same time,
the counter-reformatory message
is balanced by the tender class
of Tancredi and Clorinda's
proper left hands
and the ambiguity
of their gazes.
Whereas Tancred concentrates
on the act of baptism,
Clorinda looks lovingly
at him, not toward heaven.
The balance of sacred
and profane
in Badalocchio's
painting is pushed
to its most contumacious extreme
in Giovanni Bilivert's version,
in which Clorinda has
lost not only her helmet,
but every shred of clothing.
[ Laughter ]
I wanted to add to that.
In the cinematic version, again
from our 1957 extravaganza,
we see the exhausted warriors
helmetless and sprawled
on the bank of a river,
but with no visible wounds
or even a drop of sweat.
[laughter] I'd like
to turn now to one
of the grandest early
responses to Tasso's epic,
which was found not in
Italy, but in France.
Though the patron was the
Italian-born Marie d'Medici,
who married Henri Quatre,
Henry the Fourth, in 1600.
In the Cabinet de la
Reine at Fontainbleau,
Marie commissioned Ambroise
Dubois to paint a suite
of canvases on themes
taken from Gerusalemme.
Not surprisingly, all
of the episodes concerned
female protagonists.
Clorinda, Sofronia, and
from Heliodorus' novel,
an Ethiopian story that
focuses on Chariclea.
And some of you may
know Joaneath Spicer
at the Walters Art Museum.
She's written about
Chariclea and Clorinda
as Ethiopian princesses.
Foremost among these large
scale paintings is the combat
of Tancredi and Clorinda,
here we see it,
which bears comparison to the
composition of Domenico Mona
in his drawing from
the third canto.
Instead of the non-violent
meeting,
Dubois has chosen
the heat of battle,
where the two ill-fated lovers,
unknown to one another despite
being only clad with armor
and wearing helmets that
reveal their faces --
[laughter] -- I know,
it's crazy.
You have to suspend
a lot of disbelief.
[laughing] They're about
to wield their swords.
Since this is a painting cycle
and not an illustrated book,
the artist and patron freely
select which cantos to highlight
and which ancillary
scenes to depict.
Here we find not only
the combattimento,
but also the rarely
represented scenes of the birth
of Clorinda, which is lost.
But this one is here.
"Tancredi and Clorinda
at the Fountain,"
which is what you described
as a stream, here interpreted
by Dubois as a fountain.
The moment that Tancred's
love first blossoms, here.
Clorinda seems rather
indifferent up to the very end,
from the first canto, the 46
to 47, and to Tancred in front
of the walls of Jerusalem.
And I wanted to show
next, a very rare scene,
but it was mentioned by Laura,
of Clorinda before Arsete.
This in another drawing
by Domenico Mona -- yes.
And in this one is the moment
of the telling of the long tale
of how she's connected
to her Christian family,
including in some people's
imaginations, Prester John.
So it really has
far-reaching meaning.
This is the complete cycle,
the one I've been looking
at with Dubois, of
the encounters
between Tancredi and Clorinda.
And I bring it to your
attention for its relevance
to Monteverdi's Combattimento,
as there is nothing
comparable in Italian art.
But if Monteverdi's
intervention is more
like a musical [inaudible]
into text,
Dubois' is a visual
concordance in which every scene
where Tancredi and Clorinda
appear is brought to life.
Unlike Dubois' cycle,
Monteverdi drew his entire text
from the 12th canto, octaves
52 to 62 and 64 to 68.
In addition to allowing
the composer
to maintain Aristotle's unities
of time, space, and action,
the selections of three
episodes -- excuse me --
of these episodes, provided
a strongly pro-Christian,
anti-Turk or anti-Muslim message
for the Venetian audience
gathered for a performance
of the Combattimento in the
palace of Girolamo Mocenigo,
who was the provveditore
of the Venetian state.
And this was during Lent,
carnival season, of 1624.
Tasso's fertile poetry
offers many opportunities
to artists and composers.
They saw different things or
inflected different actions
and emotions within
the same text.
For example, Monteverdi's
"Libereto"
for the Combattimento omits the
final scene of the transport
of Clorinda to the Christian
camp, which is in Castello.
He emphasizes the
movement of the figures
from one field to the -- oops.
Sorry, I need to go one more.
There. To the next.
And closely following
Tasso's text.
Monteverdi chooses to preserve
the Aristotilian unity of place
and thus, has both the
conversion and the death
of Clorinda occur
on the battlefield.
Monteverdi inserts a
narrator called Testo,
thus the text becomes a
character in the opera and one
that allows both
Tancredi and Clorinda
to enact a choreographed battle.
And we'll see a little snippet
of this at the very end.
While he describes the action,
as well as two principle actors
and brings us into the
scene in medias res.
The Combattimento was written
in what Monteverdi called
"the genere rappresentativo,"
by which historians
of music believe that he
meant a theatrical mode.
Before the original performance,
which occurred around 1624
in the private residence I
mentioned, during the season
of Carnival, the first
audience had no clue what they
would witness.
They were enjoying the
diversions of a soiree
with strolling musicians
and conversation.
The characters entered
unexpectedly during the course
of singing madrigals.
Clorinda in armor, followed by
Tancred on a "cavallo Mariano."
Let me explain.
This term has variously
been interpreted as a kind
of capirosoned hobby horse
emblazoned with symbols
of the Virgin Mary, or possibly,
as a typo for a cavallo
marino, or sea horse.
Personally, I would love
for it to be the latter.
[laughter] A sea horse would
make the setting for the opera
in a Venetian palace
all that more --
much more marvelous
and of the period.
Monteverdi's own description
in his 8th Book of Madrigals
of love and war speaks
volumes about his intentions
and the reception of
the first performance.
They will perform --
these are his words --
steps and gestures in the
way expressed by the oration,
nothing more, nothing less.
Observing diligently those
measures, flows, and steps,
and the instrumentalists
will follow
and perform sounds
excited and soft.
In Italian, "Suane et
cher tati et mali."
And Testo, delivering the
words in measure in such a way
that the three actions come to
unite in a unified imitation.
Clorinda will speak when
appropriate, Testo, silent,
and similarly, Tancredi.
The instruments, that is, four
violi del braccio, soprano,
alto, tenor, and bass.
And a contrabasso da
gamba, which is the continuo
with a harpsichord, should
be played in imitation
of the passions of the oration.
Testo's voice should be clear,
firm, and with good delivery,
somewhat distanced
from the instruments,
so that the oration may
be better understood.
He must not remake -- or, sorry.
He must not remake "gorghe ne
trilli" which, I don't know
if we have any music
historians here,
but those are ornamentations
from the period.
So it's supposed
to be very limited,
unadorned music for
the most part.
For the rest, he will
deliver words according
to the passions of the oration.
And in this manner, now 12 years
ago, was performed in the palace
of the most illustrious
and most excellent Senor
Girolamo Mocenigo.
My particular lord,
with all refinement,
given that he is a knight of
excellent and delicate taste.
And in Carnival time, since
it was an evening pastime,
in the presence of all the
nobility, who remained moved
by the emotion of
compassion in such a way
as almost to let forth tears.
And the audience applauded
it for being a song
of a kind never before heard.
Monteverdi's Combattimento
introduced many noveta,
or novelties, to
music performance.
It is said to be the first
instance of the use of pizzicato
and tremolo in the strings,
which together added more
agitation and excitement
to the singing in
what he called the
"conchitato ," or
aroused manner.
In fact, the instrumentalists
and the singers often act
independently of one another.
There is much more to
be said, of course,
about Monteverdi's
great achievements
in this rarely performed
opera, but I don't want
to defer your pleasure
much longer.
The presentation of the video
will make things clearer
than any exegesis
could hope to do.
So in closing, it's
important to remember
that the first performance came
as a complete surprise
to all in attendance.
Perhaps these two reimaginings
of the Combattimento,
one from the 17th century that
we looked at just a minute ago,
Bilivert, and one
from the 21st century,
will serve a similar purpose.
Here, President Obama
is Tancred.
The unidentified woman, maybe
it's Hillary, is Clorinda.
And the Secret Service
man is Testo.
[laughter] Badalocchio's
version that we've been looking
at will be our final one.
Talking, laughing, dancing,
and certainly gambling,
Monteverdi drew the
raucous guest
into a single focused activity.
In keeping with the poetic
and artistic conventions
of the period,
the rappresentazione played
shamelessly on the effetti
or the effects and
emotions of the spectators.
The problem for Monteverdi
was communicating sympathy
for the protagonist when
they have so few lines.
Thus, the character of Testo
is charged with filling in all
of the details of action
and narrative tissue.
Meanwhile, the instrumentalists
are heightening emotions
and painting sound pictures
that provide a physical
setting for the actors.
When Clorinda, newly
baptized, draws her last breath
and sees heaven opening before
her, the audience is expected
to be overcome with emotion.
In Tasso's treatise,
dell'arte poetica,
he stated that the poet's role
is to move the reader to anger,
pity, or terror, to
joy or to sadness.
The original audience wept, not
because of Monteverdi's music
and stagecraft, but
because they knew Tasso's
"Gerusalemme" so well.
It was the startling
re-presentation
or re-representation
of Tasso's poetry
in Monteverdi's aroused mode
within a theatrical production
in an unexpected
palace that caused them
to experience the
epic in a new way.
And we hope that your encounter,
whether the first or the 21st,
will now be similarly informed.
This excerpt runs just
about three minutes,
and I chose the 1993 production
from the Netherlands' Opera
because it was performed in
costume with period musicians,
as Monteverdi wanted off stage
and the three principals
on stage.
Testo is performed by Guy de
Maio, who sings and emotes,
as Tancred, played by Maarten
Konigsberger, and Clorinda,
Lorna Anderson, is our Clorinda.
They sing only when Tasso has
supplied them with dialogue.
When they challenge each other
to fight, to war and death,
when Tancred begs his opponent
to name him, or in this case,
herself, he didn't know, only to
confess that she was responsible
for burning the Christian's
war machine,
further angering Tancred.
The battle ensues and
finally, the recognition
of the dying Clorinda, who
forgives Tancred and asks
for him to baptize her.
Remember, as I said, and as
Laura has said, she descends
from Christian ancestors.
And before she expires,
Tancred's interior
dialogue is voiced by Testo,
stupefied as he is,
as Laura explained,
mute and motionless, "Ahi vista!
Ahi conoscenza!"
Oh, unhappy sight,
oh woeful knowledge.
And at last, as she dies,
she bids him farewell,
I die in peace.
So if I can do this
properly, now.
[laughing] It's a little
bit of -- technology here.
And I think it's down
here on the -- yes.
Good. And it should
open where I marked it.
[music] This is Testo.
Can we do the -- yeah,
the larger screen?
[ Music ]
[ Singing in Italian ]
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Lucia Wolf: So we have a few
minutes left if anybody wants
to ask some questions.
This was wonderful.
Thank you very much.
That was a treat.
Thank you.
So we'll take some
questions if you have any.
[ Crackling ]
>> Dr. Peter Lukehart: Oh,
that's the fire crackling,
by the way, at the end here.
[laughter].
In case you're wondering
what the noise is.
[laughter] Nobody's
eating a snack.
[laughter]
>> Lucia Wolf: Yes?
>> Audience Member:
I was thinking
about Mattia Preti's
version and since we know
that Mattia Preti was very --
I mean, he had very
strong sensitivity.
I wonder if he actually was
aware about that symphony,
kind of sexual message
in the [inaudible].
And he spent a bunch
of time in Naples
and he knew a lot
of [inaudible].
So what do you think?
I mean, this is very explicit,
you know, sensual scene.
[inaudible] So probably we can
be established between the link
between the text and the
perception of the artist.
[inaudible]
>> Dr. Peter Lukehart: Yeah,
please, you can respond.
>> Dr. Laura Benedetti:
No, no, no.
Please.
>> Dr. Peter Lukehart:
Well, I --
[laughing] It's a
painting, right?
Okay. Absolutely, that's
what I believe, as well.
Is that he's making explicit
what is only implicit
in the very racy
words that Tasso used.
It's not nearly --
[laughing] as ribald
as it becomes in
Preti's painting.
But yet, there is
that undercurrent
of sexual tension
that's in the text.
And you might want to
say more about that.
>> Dr. Laura Benedetti:
Oh, absolutely, absolutely.
There's this kind of
transformation of Clorinda
in a completely different
female model, right?
I mean, from the Titan and
warrior woman to the --
[pause], you know,
Petrarchan ideal.
In fact, the language really
mirrors Petrarca when she,
in the crucial parts of the
dual and when she converts.
So there is definitely an
erotization of Clorinda,
who had, up to that moment,
completely neglected love.
So it's absolutely there.
>> Dr. Peter Lukehart: I
was going to say though
that you're linking
in beautifully here both
the erotic scene of Sofronia
and the very erotic scene of
Clorinda, as, you know, again,
taking things from the
text and making a kind
of poetic interpretation
on the basis of the artist.
[ Inaudible Question ]
>> Dr. Laura Benedetti:
Well, for Tasso,
and this is already a pretext
from Francesco DeSantis
that pointed out in Tasso there
are two different worlds really,
what it says that
it wants to do,
and what he actually
ends up doing.
So in his letters,
it's very clear.
He says, in my poem,
love is the instrument
to [inaudible] the
audience, the devil's tool.
So love is there only to
be destroyed, essentially.
Only to be defeated
at the end, right?
And in one of the first
stanzas, he says that basically,
it's poetry and love and
only the sugar coating
for the bitter medicine that
the reader is going to swallow.
[laughter] So essentially,
he has a moral message
and love is supposed to
make it more agreeable.
But at the end, what
matters is the message.
That's what he says
he intends to do.
But then, as we have
seen in these characters,
he's very convincing
when he talks about love
and these characters seem
to take a life of their own.
And so when he tried to, in a
way, to really limit all of that
and come out with the
"Gerusalemme conquistata,"
the public didn't follow that.
So I -- he seems to be
championing a different,
more modern way of love.
Luckily for us, he actually
succeeded in expressing some
of the most beautiful
love stories
that have ever been written.
>> Lucia Wolf: On that note,
a beautiful note, love.
[laughter] If you're done?
If you're not, we will continue,
but I think it's
time to wrap this up.
I'm sorry if I interrupted.
>> Dr. Laura Benedetti:
No, we just wanted
to thank everybody,
including our public.
[laughter] Thank you so much.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us as loc.gov.